[Music]
in hamster hell News Online wise about
she's thinking that I like hamsters and
I just saw a bunch of hamsters
exercising like crazy and I felt bad for
them because then I saw a hamster and
then it said hell I just saw like 20 of
them on the wheel and they want to stop
it but they can I saw a hamster video
recently the hamster he's holding it and
then the hamsters just like petting his
hand and like nuzzle yeah oh I don't
know I like critters like with him like
30 another grounders don't agree okay
good load our key knows we're talking
about Hell hamster Helen what's going on
submitted by Justine from Washington
hello Washington a hamster that a woman
bought for her children destroyed her
new car oh [ __ ] [ __ ] like a bear it's
like a monster hand cut and she want
some wires yeah yeah I just pictured the
muffler yeah girls call [ __ ] hammond
cars
what cuz it made like to nibble on [ __ ]
so like in our neighborhood I go under
yeah they want to get rid of all the
squirrels I'm like why
and then it's because they're [ __ ] up
their car like they go in the car and
[ __ ] on I not inside but like around
it they cut the brake lines and [ __ ] the
hell the gangster yeah they just went
grab a corner start keying the [ __ ] out
of no they clog up the mufflers yeah
such dogs start humping the windshield
wipers yeah do you just a lot a little
man you lost me there I got the rest of
it how do you a humble wish a white bird
antenna and they tie it in a knot soon
get reception
you haven't seen squirrel nuts they look
exactly like human nuts how do you um
hump a Winchell library these are climb
up and down like firefighter like a
stripper pole yeah I wonder what
squirrel tastes like I've had a friend
that ate it really was it good I didn't
need it he was a savage yeah why do you
eat a squirrel yeah no time
no he's just messing around he shot with
like a BB gun in the native yeah but I'm
also like if I was in the wild or like
an apocalypse happen right could I eat a
squirrel
hell yeah desperate enough your you'll
eat a dog if you have to fall yeah yeah
yeah it's either me or not me either
human yeah people have you many Donna
Haas did the dumber
I probably had a human before a dog whoa
really good for you I guess we got
barbecue so cuz the dog is good alive
for me cuz when I'm sleeping the dog is
gonna be my garden a human like actually
exactly speak to you yeah by then the
human I don't know it depends on what
kind of human I'm talking about our
enemy so like let's say we have our
mindset about disposable humans I'm not
even deport we're the same cruel right
we're in the same cruel on an island
right there's a couple of youtubers feel
like right barbecue mother they're
probably gonna taste like [ __ ] I would
just kill them and eat them
yeah even I'm not hungry that's just
kind of so funny I would just kill them
it can you get sick from eating human
I'm sure probably I mean it's just
protein bother you you sick from eating
I think there's certain parts of you
what are you doing medium rare I mean an
extra you sick it's not the actual meat
right it's always like a bacteria humans
got sickness alright cannibalism I don't
believe in cannibalism that's that you
know for me hamsters are cannibals I
said well eat squirrel oh yeah the other
way all right so this mom here she's a
mom of four she kind of funny so this is
how she starts her post uh her name's
Amanda by the way she says we began the
35 minute drive home full of excitement
with our new family member but then the
hamster somehow got out of the box oh
sure she signs twenty minutes into the
journey I felt something brush past my
left ankle I scratched it and carried on
driving it happened again I looked and
there's a [ __ ] hamster
there's a [ __ ] hamster set under the
[ __ ] clutch pedal oh no he's like
smashing in the head
she's like holy [ __ ] not stopping
allow no stopping allowed on the roads
so had to drive the rest of the way home
knowing there's a [ __ ] hamster on the
loose in my car oh I am absolutely and
then she's starting to say that she left
about the kid took the hamster out huh
no like you probably chewed through the
bottom of the box or something and I'm
sure it's a kid wait I wanna hold you
cause if I was a kid I'm taking that
[ __ ] out in the car yeah but
wouldn't the kids say some [ __ ] like
mommy no they're gonna get dude I mean I
would have said it I'm pulling that [ __ ]
cuz I'm just like I think I can get him
back yep that's what I happened when I
accidentally let my bird out and then
flew off honestly I'm not saying [ __ ]
and then I went out to play with my
friends and I heard it squawking from
the neighbor's house I was looking for
my house
so was in the neighbor's driveway and I
put it back in no one knew about it I
would sacrifice my I put all hands on
deck I [ __ ] the world in the back
seat on the top if I'm her I'm pulling
over I'm freaking out I'm pulling over
yeah she said that she couldn't pull
over on this road I don't believe my
shoulders just emergency brake lights
and just slow down so this is the hurt
she's had this car for four months so
it's a brand new car oh no she she said
that it's been days already that bad
she's heartbroken about her new car but
despite the damage you would like to
find the hamster left alive but then
anyway she said she ended up saying that
this fool he has destroyed the passenger
door airbags and why this dude wins will
work
that's like thousands of dollars yes
there's gonna be no there no wait did
she Park in a hamster just they couldn't
find him for days hmm
mr. has avoided eight trap that she said
is a car car like she still needed so
she still needs to drive it to so she's
like [ __ ] I know there's a hamster in
your AC to drive it around things are
breaking apart while she's driving and
enough we just made a house
yeah you've destroyed her seatbelt I'm I
destroyed it what's probably hungry or
just born I don't know if answers are
the same but rats they have to nibble on
stuff they just like to file down the
team these nipples through everything I
hated him so this is a mama for Amanda
what happened to your rat they just died
oh yeah they don't have a long life long
lifespan they were feeder nice to you
rats oh they're not even shorter yeah
the damage caused these [ __ ] are nice
called exterminators yeah what he did I
get two for different mechanics she said
and they couldn't find the hamster
dominator dude and that they well she
doesn't want to call it she doesn't want
to kill the house I'm sure they can trap
it there's like humane exterminator well
that's why I should keep getting traffic
control control there you go sorry my
bed
there's humane executioner's whatever
it's hiding in there it's like the
easiest place to look she's like what
you heard trapped work she's why don't
you get her killed she ordered them
online or whatever rat traps traps day
one I would have had my kid just reach
under me and grab it while I'm driving
if you know exactly where it is mm-hmm
we got the last report of day here's day
six he's dead she's keeping it bury like
a [ __ ] apocalypse
she's updating her social media I
thought the hamster was just in the cup
or a little hole time okay well [ __ ] is
his hamster
that's crazy middle huh but then they
finally found him no well I'm telling
you the last reported date oh it's just
a c6
so can't get that hipster out damn I
feel like a hamster dump it
are you you suppose like how you gonna
connect with that little critter I think
you can somehow I don't know about a
hamster speaking right I said I told you
the video there's a hamster like pets
whose owners like fingers like hugs it
it's so yeah rats I think are smart and
I love it thank you little they're
stupid rubbing oh yeah cute yeah cuz I
love it yeah you go like this and then
they like pool their ears good I like
cleaning everything so they would clean
themselves all the time but yeah this
poor lady her brand-new car is destroyed
I did that once
not the car but like I found a rat when
I was really really young like I loved
kid the kids I loved animals like my
whole life so I found a rat and in our
house and then um I brought it at home
and then was like do you have their
necks like what disease its own asked to
get rid of it and then I guess she
scared me and it just jumped out of my
hand and at that time we had a hole in
the ground and it's the above the
above-ground baby in your help yeah you
just [ __ ] everything up oh [ __ ]
for how long I live it to the right and
I mean you know when you're a kid it
like you're just in that moment and then
you just forget about everything so I
had probably exterminate it do it like
if you mean if there was a [ __ ] if
there's a hamster my car doing damage
[ __ ] it I think it's dying
I'm finding a way to kill it like get
the [ __ ] out of my car especially a
brand new car yeah that's pretty patient
mom yeah just drive your car into the
desert and just leave it parks fire yeah
let us scurry out oh I think you see
like off the place no cuz it's hottest I
mean like that's how kids and dogs get
killed if they'll get left in the car
yeah you think even even just like
overnight though if you just like put in
your garage and like open doors or
something maybe run out drink alright Oh
put a cat in there that should all find
it fast it scratches the [ __ ] out of
everything
okay now we put a dog in there good at
this all right
got a goddamn zoo in your garage is that
a [ __ ] up ecosystems when they introduce
like invasive species and if you get
another one in another one is in Florida
I think what yeah because people will
get them as pets and then they
disappeared there that baby now there's
like too many anacondas around for sure
there was a ruler of some sort who like
was so sick of like these pests or
whatever so they introduced oh these
birds that were destroying the crops so
they introduced like cats whatever to
kill all those birds and then they went
into a famine because of some [ __ ] or
another mm-hmm I mean that sounds yeah
believable humans [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah
[Music]